right
hello everyone um my name is scott
veloshan
this is a talk called building
confidence in concurrent code
using a model checker
otherwise known as tla plus for
programmers so we'll be using a tool
called tla plus that
you might or might not heard of um my
name scott veloson
and um i i have a website f sharp for
fun and profit which is
about f sharp this talk is not about f
sharp it's a completely
different kind of thing but um
it will have too much information this
talk there's no way you can explain all
this stuff in an hour
so i'm going to cram a lot of stuff in
and
really just to demystify things and just
to make
make you see that this is not as scary
as you might think it is and it's a
whole new tool that
you might find useful uh i will be
showing the slides
later on and i think the video will be
available uh later on as well
so okay why why am i focusing on
concurrent code
um you know there's people who've
written concurrent code and there's
people who've had
weird painful bugs in the current code
and the combination of these two people
the intersection is a perfect circle
uh everyone has written code has
probably had weird
painful bugs now you can get with but
you get no bugs in normal code but
they're not as weird and not as painful
as bugs in concurrent code
so how can we you know get confident
about our codes we want to get confident
about concurrent code we want to get
confident about you know regular code
how how people how many people actually
are confident about that code
so i did a poll and i asked a new
programmer um
you know what do they think of their
code and
they often say something like you know
this code doesn't work this code doesn't
work
and i don't know why uh because i'm a
new programmer
i don't have a lot of experience um so
no confidence there now if you ask a
battle scarred
veteran programmer who is kind of grumpy
all the time
they will often say this code works and
i don't know why
they just don't trust that their code
works even when it does work
so you know you can get you can lack
confidence in your code even if you're a
very experienced programmer so you know
this is a bit of a problem
so what do we do as developers what do
we do to improve our confidence
in our codes well we have a lot of
things to do at the design
phase we have domain driven design and
behavior design
and rapid prototyping and uml diagrams
and all this stuff
all this stuff is trying to make sure
we're doing the right thing before we
start coding
and then when we're coding we can use a
statically typed programming language to
avoid stupid things like nulls
and we can have good well-debugged
libraries and then we have testing which
helps you know your test driven
development and property-based testing
and canary testing
all these things improve the confidence
in our code
before we put it into production so i'm
going to introduce you to another tool
which is model checking and
as i said the goal of this talk is to
show you a different way of thinking
about
checking your code it's another useful
tool for your toolbox it's not meant to
be
a replacement for everything but it's
just another thing to add and it's very
very valuable in certain circumstances
and what do i mean by model checking so
here is a model
this is an architectural model every
every engineering discipline uses models
of various kinds
and a model is a tool for thinking um
the idea is you make a model and you
look at it and you say you know is this
what i want
you can check things make sure they make
sense make sure that everyone else is
happy with it
before you actually do the costly
implementation
so with a building you have a model
before you actually start construction
process
but even for software you know if you
spend a few hours playing with a model
it's still a lot cheaper than spending a
couple of weeks
doing the implementation so models are
always a good tool and like i say it's
it's a way of thinking it helps you
think about your design clearly before
you kind of get bogged down by the
implementation details
so what is this model checking thing
from a software point of view
well we're going to build a model using
a special sort of domain specific
language
and then we're going to check the model
and there's a model checker that checks
the model
and it checks things like you know all
the constraints met
does anything unexpected happen does it
deadlock
all the different things that you might
want to check does the is the model
consistent in some way
you want to check this and the model
checker will check that for you
and this is really a whole
part of the formal methods approach to
software engineering
and this is kind of one subsection of
that and
it's actually very convenient to do it's
not as scary as you think
so currently i think would i would say
the two most popular model checking
systems
are tla plus uh the model checkers
actually called tlc but i'm just going
to call it tla plus
everywhere just to be consistent really
to make it easy and it really focuses on
temporal properties it's excellent of
that
and so it's really good for modelling
concurrent systems you can model all
sorts of stuff but
the current systems in particular are
very good there's another one called
alloy
and the model is the model checker is
called alloy analyzer
and it focuses on relational logic and
it's really good for modeling structures
um they're both very good um tl tla plus
is the one we're going to use today
because we're going to be talking about
concurrent systems
and tla plus is excellent for that so
this is what some tla plus code looks
like
and the first time i saw this code
i thought this is the weirdest looking
programming language
i've ever seen and the reason why it's a
weird-looking programming language is
because it's not a programming language
that's why it's weird looking um
it is actually mathematics
anyway so by the end of this talk uh you
should be able to make some sort of
sense of this code
uh not necessarily obviously be able to
understand it completely but it won't
look quite as intimidating
so i'm going to try and do some live
polling here there is a
uh a link here bitly slash
tla poll bitly slash tla poll
and i want you to type that into your
browser if you're following along
and i i'm gonna see if um is anyone is
listening
and let's see if we can get any results
on this so
bitly tla poll see
if we have any results here 100 of
people can see this poll
wow that's amazing nobody says they
can't see it
that's very good
excellent so just go back to for the
people who didn't see it it is
bitly tla paul and i'll be doing some
more questions in a minute
so please get ready and type this in and
i'll i'll provide the link again if you
didn't get it bitly
tll poll and
yeah 100 100 score on the poll that's
awesome
good okay now let's
go on so who can see this poll one
hundred percent of the people
very good all right so the talk what i'm
going to talk about
is confidence i'm going to talk about
tla plus
and then i'm going to use tla plus to
solve some examples
i'm going to use a very very simple
model and then i'm going to do a
producer consumer model
and a zero downtime deployment model and
i'm going to
try and squeeze all of this into an hour
i think i will go over by a couple of
minutes
but um i'll i'll speak very fast
all right so part one is confidence um
confidence is a preference for the
habitual voyeur of what is known as
sort algorithms um here is a
specification
for a sword algorithm to sort a list
if the list is empty or has one element
it's already sorted so just return it
if the list is not sorted take the first
element
and divide the other elements into two
piles one
less than and one greater than and then
sort each of those piles in turn
and then the final result is the whole
thing
by concatenating the smaller list sorted
then the pivot element and then the
bigger list sorted
okay so how how how is your confidence
level on this
um how can you have confidence that this
algorithm
is correct okay now not the
implementation but this algorithm is
this algorithm right does it work
how would you how would you do that how
would you get confidence in this
um let me ask you before
i tell you how i would so who thinks
this is a correct
specification for a sort algorithm
and i think i need to move to the next
question over here
there we go
who thinks it's the correct
implementation who's not sure
this is live polling this is very
exciting
a lot of people are not sure
yeah i think that's
uh where we are right now
so that's not uh it's uh
that's there you go this is life in the
big city so um
most people are not very confident so so
what could we do and in fact you're
calling right to be not common because
there's actually a logic bug here
this should be less than or equal or
greater than equal one of the ways
because we're throwing away duplicates
so that's actually a logic bug um so how
can we gain confidence well one thing is
to do
code review and careful inspection of
the code and just have someone else go
through it line by line
that's not bad approach one way is to
actually create an implementation
and then test that implementation and
that's not necessarily a bad approach
either
for example property based tests would
be perfect for this
and the final way would be to use like a
mathematical proof assistant tool
like clock or something and that is
probably overkill
really for something like this now so
personally what i'd probably do is use
code review
and careful inspection of the code and
then
things like property based tests would
be a fantastic way of finding bugs in
this kind of code it will probably find
this bugs
straight away so for linear
single threaded codes the tools that we
have the tools that you're used to
work pretty well now how confident are
you
when concurrency is involved okay so if
you're not confident about a sort
algorithm
how confident are you about something
more complicated and generally
people are very unconfident about
concurrency so here we have a queue
and the producer writes to the queue and
the logic we're going to do for the
producer is
they're going to check if the queue is
not full and if it's not full we're
going to write the item to the queue and
we're going to do it in two separate
steps it's not going to be an atomic
step because otherwise it wouldn't be a
very interesting problem
and then we have the consumer reading
from the queue and they do the same
thing their way around
if the queue is not empty they can read
and if the queue
is empty they can't read and so they're
just going to loop doing that so we have
a
producer and a consumer right so here is
the spec and we've got one producer
we're going to start off with one
producer and one consumer and we have
some constraints that we must never
never break
we must never try to read from an empty
queue and we never try to add
to a full queue because the whole system
will crash and burn and it'll be
complete disaster hopefully our system
is a bit more robust but in some
situations you know
you don't want to read past the end of a
buffer for example
so here's the spec again basically check
step and then right step and on the
consumer side
you do a check step and then you do a
read step okay
so who thinks that this spec is correct
and the constraints will always be met
let me go back i have to
move the poll forward here there you go
what is the
confidence in the design of this
producer consumer system
right so who thinks it's not correct who
thinks it is correct and who's not sure
and it's a trap by the way this is a
trap question
it's a trick question anything with
concurrency is a trick question
because you're never quite sure is this
the right answer or not
so we have um yeah we have it
you know let's see some people is
confident it's not correct
some people are confident that it is
correct and some people are not sure
either way
you just never know with concurrency
it's kind of scary
yeah so it seems like
not that many people are sure that it's
correct there's a lot of people who are
confident it's not correct
and it's a lot of people who are not
sure either way
now i'm not going to tell you the answer
we're going to actually check
use a model checker to check this later
on but i do have a question for the
people who said they were not sure
and this is i'm deploying this to like a
mission critical system
how could i persuade you how could i
make you confident how could i say yeah
i'm you know i i changed my mind i am
really 100 sure
or i'm 100 not sure i mean 100 confident
either way
what could i do to give you confidence
um think about that now let's change the
logic so we have two producers
and two consumers right the first one
had one producer one consumer
and we'll do the same poll again and
you tell me if
uh to produce a consumer with more than
one clients or you know yeah everyone
seems to think it's not correct
so it's exactly the same producer
consumer both do things you want to make
sure you never overrun the queue
or under under run the queue and um
there's two
producers and two consumers and most
people seem to think it is not correct
and that's because you're scared of
concurrency that's good
so for people who voted not sure again
how could i persuade you and for the
people who thought it was incorrect
i come along and i say okay i have a fix
for this
uh that i'll solve this problem how can
you how can i persuade you that that fix
is actually correct
i mean you're not very confident that
this is correct um
what would make your comp you know i say
i have this magic fix i'm going to use
locks or something
how would you be confident that my fix
was correct what would make you
confident
that's a tricky problem so being
in concurrent systems is really hard
uh and so all the tools we normally have
for gaining confidence don't really work
for concurrency
if we try and do careful inspection and
code of view our human intuition is just
rubbish
for concurrency really bad uh if we try
and create an implementation
and test it uh that doesn't work very
well either because many concurrency
errors
occur you know one in a thousand times
they might never ever show up
um and we could use a mathematical proof
assistant
um and that's basically what we're going
to do except we're just going to do a
model checker it's a mathematical
concept but it's not actually doing a
full-fledged proof it's just going to
check the model for consistency
and that's a much much easier approach
and that's what we're going to talk
about right now
and as i said we will revisit the
producer consumer problem
later on and check it for ourselves
so that brings us to tla plus
and uh again don't i'm going to go
through this quite quickly don't
understand don't worry if you don't
understand it
um the goal is really to demystify
uh tla a bit for you so stand back
i'm going to use mathematics uh
tla plus is not a programming language
it's a mathematical way of doing things
so tla is designed.helioplus was
designed by leslie lampert
you might have heard of he's got a
famous time and clocks paper
he invented the paxos algorithm for
consensus he's a touring award winner
and he is the initial developer of latex
and there is a photo of him
the latex thing is relevant because tla
plus uses the same kind of syntax as
latex
which is so it's going to look familiar
if you're used to latex and it's going
to look weird if you're used to
programming languages so tla plus
stands for temporal logic of actions
plus some stuff so let's let's break
that down
into those words the logic part that's
something to do with booleans
so that's straightforward we know how
booleans work um
temporal means something to do with time
and actions
in this case is going to be transitions
of a
state machine so
if you think of tla as a system which is
a boolean logic of state transitions
over time
uh it's still it sounds less scary uh
i'm going to explain exactly what that
means it's not as scary as you might
think
and there's some other stuff too which
we will come to later on
so let's look at the logic part in tla
plus so the logic is boolean
logic uh and hopefully you all know how
that works you've got and
and or and not and the mathematical
symbols
are upside down triangle uh you know
triangles up and down
and it's easy to remember that the a in
and
matches the triangle so it looks like
the letter a and the upside down
triangle is or
in programming we use ampersand and
vertical bars
but tla plus uses the mathematical style
and that's why it has these weird
forward slashes and backward slashes
everywhere
um that is just the and and the or from
tla plus
for the mathematical style tla plus now
when you run it through a nice formatter
like latex
it comes out looking like the
mathematical style so
the coding the code kind of looks ugly
and it gets formatted much more nicely
by the time you finished
now another word i'm going to use a lot
is a predicate
and that is just an expression that
returns a boolean the test
if you like uh in a programming language
a predicate or a test looks like this
you have some
a function and it's an a and b or
a and not c and in tla plus you would
write it
the same way but using the the different
symbols so you see
a and b or a and not
c uh so the symbols are different the
way it
looks is very different but the concepts
are exactly the same
so if you've written a program that does
a test a function that does a test
you can write tla that does test exactly
the same way
so okay now what about the actions so
the actions in tla are
state transitions so what do i mean by a
state transition
um well we're going to we're going to
model our system as a bunch of different
states
and the transitions between them so here
we have state a and state b
and we can go from a to b and we can go
from b to c
and we can go from b back to a again we
can't from c state c we can't go
anywhere
so this is like all the different things
we can do in this system
uh like a chess game you say and it's
white's turn and after white's turn we
transition to black's turn and after
baxter
we go back to white's turn and if white
wins the game's over
and once the game's over you can't
transition anywhere or a delivery system
where it's undelivered and then it's out
for delivery
and then it's delivered and once it's
delivered you can't transition anywhere
and so on so this is a great way to
model uh most processes we're not
talking about millions and millions of
states we're talking about you know a
few
states to model and all the transitions
so it's something you can kind of keep
in your head
so in tla here are two states and one
transition
and it's going to transition from hello
to goodbye
and this is the state before and this is
the state afterwards
and in tla you would write it like this
state equals hello
before and in the state afterwards you'd
write
state tick equals goodbye
so that little tick means afterwards
mathematicians will call that state
prime
equals goodbye that means you're some
kind of a modification of the original
state
so every time you see that tick that
means it's the after state and if you
don't see the tick
it's the before state so the action
is the transition and this is how you
would write it
let's say we have a transition called
next uh in tla
we define it like this next equals state
equals hello and
state prime equals goodbye
and in english we'd say the state before
is hello
and the state after is goodbye
now this equals is not an assignment
it's an equals it's like is the
afterwards state equal to goodbye
so this is a test it's not an assignment
and you can prove that it's a test
because if you swap
these two segments that works just as
well in in
from a logical point of view the
afterwards is goodbye and the before is
hello
that's exactly the same thing um that
doesn't work with programming languages
but it does work with logic so
this is really important actions are not
assignments they're tests
so here we have a test is the state
before hello and the state after goodbye
if it is that's good but here when it
doesn't match the state afterwards is
ciao that doesn't work
here the state before is haldi well that
doesn't work either
so it's it's it's it's testing whether
the states match
the condition to do the trend uh the
transition
that's what an action is right now let's
look at the temporal
in tla plus temporal for time
so ti plus models uh the state
transactions
over time in fact over an infinite
amount of time to you know imagine a
little clock ticking you know one second
two seconds three second form each time
we transition to a different state
and of course time goes on forever and
so the states go on forever too
and because of that you can ask
questions like is something always true
for every single possible state is
something ever true is there one state
where it becomes true
and if it happens if something happens
does something else have to happen
afterwards
those are temporal questions those are
the questions over time
and tla is excellent at answering those
kinds of questions
so temporal logical actions same as
boolean
logic of state transitions over time so
just just one way to think about it
so that's everything you need to know
about tla for now
and we will save the plus for later
okay now let's move on and use tla plus
to build a very very simple model and
the model we're going to pick
is counting to three that's the that's
how
complicated this model is going to be so
i bet your programming language can't do
that
so okay let's look at counting to three
um
we have three states we start in one and
then we go to two then we go to three
and in a programming language um we say
x equals one
and then x equals two and then x equals
three so that's very very exciting
um let's see how we would do the same
thing
in tla plus so
i'm just going to put the code down this
is what the code looks like
and then i will explain what it means so
the first thing is we have an initial
state
uh state position the state machines can
always be described by saying
what's the initial state and then what
are all the transactions to go between
the states
so initially starts with x equals one
uh and then um the next
transition is x equals one and
afterwards x equals two
and the next transition is x equals two
and then afterwards x equals three
and then the overall next thing is
matching
either those transitions it's either
either the first one or
the second one so the overall complete
set of transitions we can do is the
first one or the second one
so that's we're going to define the next
operator to be that
all right so that's our complete tla
plus
spec for counting to 3. now let's do a
quick refactor
what we've done here is we've created
two helper
functions as it were two new steps um
just to make life a bit easier and these
things are not really functions these
are actually called
operators and you can actually think of
as more like macros
they're literally copy and paste kind of
thing you take take them and copy and
paste them around
so after we've got these little we've
kind of pulled these out into their own
steps
the overall next step is a lot easier to
read it just says do step one
or do step two so this is a little nicer
to read
than the first version okay so that's
our complete spec for counting to three
now let's let's show you how to run it
so the best way to run it is probably
something called the tla plus
toolbox which is sort of the ide the tla
plus
there is an extension for bs code but
you sort of have to know what you're
doing the tla
toolbox has a nice user interface um
it's written in java it's kind of a bit
of a 90s user interface i wouldn't say
the user interface is the best part
about it but
it does work so you type your code into
a
into a editor there and it you
run it and you make sure there's no
syntax errors that's the first bit okay
so now we've got
our our code now we create a model
and for a model we have to say what's
the first state and what's the next
state
that's the what's the state transition
so we just say to the model okay
you start within it and all the possible
things you can do are next
and then we click the run button and it
runs the model checker
and what happens well first of all it
detects that there are three distinct
states
which is good that's hopefully there are
three distinct states
and then it also says deadlock reached
and that doesn't sound very good that
sounds a bit scary
what does it mean by deadlock so we go
and look at the error
and there's a little uh trace and it
says it went from one and then it went
to two and then went to three and then
it stopped
and this is the problem the problem is
that it stopped
um it went to three
and there was no forward progress that
could be made here
and if you can't make any forward
progress if there's no valid transition
that you can do that's what tla plus
calls a deadlock
literally you're just stopped and so in
this situation
our count to three example it deadlocks
when it reaches three so that's not very
good
so um the main thing is it's really
important to be aware that uh these
state machines really do have to be
infinite series
of state transitions over time time
doesn't just stop
you know after three seconds at stake
three but what what's where should it be
at four seconds in five seconds and six
seconds
you've got to tell it so um in our case
well we're done
when we hit three so let's just have a
transition that okay when you're at
three you can go to three again
and then you go to three again and then
you can go to three again
and you can just keep looping at three
and that's and then we're done
okay so let's add that to the model um
we're going to add a loop on the three
and we're going to add
a new step called done so to say that
you just don't do anything and you just
stay put
you can say there's a special keyword
called unchanged so the x is unchanged
it just loops back on itself
so now um we have the loop
and we have this new final step saying
it's done when x equals three
and at that point it just stays
unchanged so the overall thing is now
three steps it's either step one or it's
step two or it's done
now if we run this new model against
with the with the model checker
it sounds great um no no deadlock
everything's happy
okay so that's a very complicated way of
counting to three
um now one thing before we move on
is i should just point out that doing
nothing is almost always an option
um let me show you two different
infinite series of states here's a
here's a
here's a state machine that counts one
two three and four five whatever
here's another one um now in the first
one you may say well this one runs every
you know second one two three the second
one
you know a millisecond after the first
one nothing's happened
um it just transitions from one to one
and two to two
and three to three and and really is
there any difference between these two
systems
um from a time point of view i mean
every second
the clock ticks and it goes from one to
two to three and the fact that nothing
happened between
one you know in a millisecond really
they're exactly the same system
and so they need to be modeled as the
same system
and and pretty much staying in the same
state is almost always a valid
state transition and tla uh has a word
for that called stuttering meaning
you're just not doing anything you're
just sitting around not making any
progress
so we need to add stuttering it's always
good practice to add stuttering to your
model
so we're going to add stuttering so you
can hang around in one and you can hang
around in two
and we just add that again to our next
step
you see there's a step one or step two
or it's done or nothing changes
okay so that's the added stuttering now
so our model we're building up our model
we're adding new things to a model
um so now let's talk about time
so we've got a very complicated
complicated way of
counting to three um it's not very
exciting
but that's not the point of doing tla
plus
the point of play plus is you can do a
lot more than that um
and so let's start doing these extra
things that your programming language
can't do we're going to check some
temporal properties
temporal properties properties that are
meaning have some sort of meaning over
time okay
so a property applies to the entire
system
over time not just to any individual
state to any one time
and so checking these kinds of
properties is really really important
um and this is the kind of thing that
humans are really bad at
checking that the queue size it never
goes beyond
bounds it's really hard for us to kind
of see that when you have multiple
producers and
consumers you know programming languages
are really bad at this too
an average programming language is not
designed for this kind of thing however
tla plus is designed for this kind of
thing tla plus is excellent at this kind
of thing
so let's use tla plus to do it
so what kinds of properties can we check
what's useful in our world of
modeling well a very important property
is that something is always true
right well you want to make sure that in
our you know the q case that the the
queue never goes below zero um
in our in our count to three example uh
we could say that the q
that our number x is always greater than
zero you know it goes one two three if
it goes below
one something went wrong um another
useful one is something is eventually
true
um in our case is it true that at some
point in time
x equals two well yeah is it true at
some point in time that x equals
42 no it isn't um eventually always
it's an interesting one and you use this
for where something is
done so when it you know eventually
something becomes done
it's not always done but eventually it
does become done but when it does become
done it stays done
uh and in our case x eventually becomes
three
and then it stays there it kind of it's
done at that point our counting
three is done and it just kind of loops
around staying at three so that's what's
called eventually always
and another useful one is leading to um
so if x7 becomes two then i guarantee it
will become a three later
uh but if i said if x becomes three i
guarantee it'll become one later
uh that's not true so um
we have to kind of formalize this
because we're using kind of informal
language so we need to cut it into kind
of mathematical language
so in english when we say something is
always greater than two we really mean
that it's always true
that x is greater than zero and in in
tla
we use the kind of square brackets as
the always operator
when we say at some point x is two the
more formal way of saying that is it's
eventually true
that x equals true at x equals two
that's something in some state
and again in tla plus there's a special
operator for that which is the
angle brackets one um
x eventually becomes three and then
stays there
that's one of these eventually always
things so it's eventually
it's true that eventually always x is
three
so always x three is not true at the
beginning but eventually
it is true and the symbol for that in
tla plus is the angle brackets followed
by the square brackets
and then finally if x ever becomes two
then it will become three later
um that's in uh tla
we use a kind of wiggly arrow for that
so those are kind of really important
properties that
all sorts of uses and we will see uh
this used later on when we come to the
more complex examples
so let's add these properties to the
script always
x is one is greater than one it's less
than three so it's always within bounds
uh so we're going to use the square
brackets for always and then we just say
x is greater than one and
x is less than three that's always true
no matter what state is in
at some point x equals two so we're
going to use the angle brackets
at some point eventually x equals two
at some point x equals 3 and stays there
so
this time we use the eventually always
which is the angle brackets followed by
the square brackets
and then whenever x is 2 then x does
become 3 and we use the
the twiddly arrow for that okay so
that's the um
properties and in in the model checker
we kind of have to add the tell the
model checker that we want to check them
there's a little bit of a user interface
we can do that so i want to check all
these four properties and
make sure they're always true no matter
how i run the model
um so here we have the properties again
and we're going to ask another poll
how many of these properties are true
let me go to the
whole thing here how many of these
properties are true
all four of them some of them one of
them or none of them
okay so and i promise you i haven't made
any typos
these are this is the correct way of
specifying these properties
so that's not it's not a type of kind of
thing it's like from a logical point of
thing
will these properties always be true
so this is your this is your confidence
test
and most people seem to think that all
four of them will be true
and a couple of people think that some
of them will be true
okay so it's tla it's bitly tla pol
if you're following along at home
and yeah i i think i'm just going to say
vast majority of people think that all
four are correct
some people think that some of them are
correct
nobody thinks that anything else is
right so
yet again your intuition is wrong
because if we actually run this um
we want this little thing and the model
checker says uh-oh
temporal properties were violated
now what happens well if i look at the
the trace it says it started at one
and then it stayed at one and then it
stayed at one it stayed at one it
started
it just kept going round and round what
we've got here is one infinite loop
because you forgot that i added this
infinite loop to the one state
and this is really easy to do um and so
what happened here
is that it never got out of the first
state and so none of the other
properties were true
um one of the properties was true which
is the bounds was it always within
bounds
yes it was it was always uh you know
greater equal than one and less than
equal three because the very first state
that was true um but none of the other
ones came true because it never left the
first
state that's kind of annoying we went to
this trouble
to add this stuttering thing because
we're supposed to add it to represent a
good model
and yet as soon as we add it um it
complains
that it's just stuck in an infinite loop
uh that's not very helpful
so how can how can we fix this um
we want what we want to do is it's like
it's okay i don't mind if you go around
that loop a few times
but i want you to at least try some
other things don't just go around the
same place forever you know
try some of the other transitions once
in a while
um so that's what we wanted to do and
there's actually a word for this this is
called fairness
don't just pick on one transition and
stick to it
try all the other transitions give all
the other transitions a chance
um don't just just don't stick with one
of them
so of course tla plus can model this
and so let's see how tla plus does do
model it
so how do we model fairness in tla plus
uh we have to do some
kind of bit of code refactoring again uh
and then we can add the fairness and
unfortunately the syntax for this gets a
bit ugly
so just bear with me the first thing we
have to do
is get rid of the initial and next
transitions
and merge them into a single
specification which
which encompasses everything so rather
than saying here's the initial one
here's the next one
we're going to have something that
combines both of them so we're going to
say the overall specification
is going to be the initial step the
initial state
and then always something else some sort
of trans state transition
okay now the state transition is either
the next transition or the unchanged
transition
so it's either do the next step or do
one of these infinite loops
and always do one of the two so that's
uh
the overall specification the way we
have it right now
okay so this is what it looks like right
now but then there's a special syntax
for that
to make it look nicer and it looks like
this so that's what it looks like before
and that's what it looks like afterwards
um
this special syntax when you have the
little underscore that means
stutter on x so it says try to do the
next transition or
stutter on x and they're both good
all right so that's what we've got right
now now finally we can add the fairness
constraints and this is what it looks
like wf
underscore x of next and i told you the
syntax is a bit kind of
gnarly this is called weak fairness
there's actually another one called
strong fairness and i'm really not going
to get into the difference
but what this basically does says is
don't keep going round and round in
circles try doing the next transition
every so often
if it's available just don't get stuck
in a loop
that's all that means so here's our
complete spec with fairness now we've
added the fairness constraint
and here are properties to check so this
is the complete spec now for counting to
three
and if we run this new spec all four
temporal properties are now
true which is great so what we were
missing we just needed to add that
fairness thing
to make sure it didn't get stuck in a
loop and these properties are true just
as we thought they would be originally
that's nice so now we're done so we can
count to three
that's very exciting now this is the
thing so counting the three is not the
exciting part
what the exciting part is that these
four properties
checking whether something's always true
eventually true eventually always true
and so on
these are the things that you can do in
tla plus that you can't do
in a programming language so this is the
really the point i want to make about
this little example
uh um know we this is the stuff that's
the critical stuff
okay so now let's move on to
the producer consume examples that we
did earlier in the talk and let's see if
we can model them
and get confidence rather than
everyone's saying well i don't know i'm
not sure i don't have a lot of
confidence
let's see if we can get rid of that and
get some confidence
so here's the examples again we write to
a queue
we've got two different stages we read
from the queue
and we have two different stages so now
let's what we're going to do is make a
model of this in tla plus
and we're going to check the model and
see what the model says
rather than just guessing so on the
producer side of things
there's actually two different states uh
we start off we're ready to write
and then we can see is it can we
actually write is the queue full or not
if the queue is not full we can
transition to the right stage and then
at that point when our turn comes around
again
we can try writing and after we've
written something we go back to ready
and we start all over again so as i said
we're going to model this as two
distinct transitions rather than one
atomic step because if it was one atomic
step it would be a really boring example
so the programming language version of
this if i was doing this in
like python or some pseudocode this is
not exactly python but
if the cue size is less than the maximum
size
and we're in the ready states then we
can transition
to the right state that's the first bit
and then second bit
is uh if we're in the can write state
then transition back to the ready state
and as also as part of that
uh change the queue size push something
onto the queue
now since this is a model i actually
don't care what the contents of the
queue is at
all the only thing i really care about
is the queue getting bigger or is it
getting smaller
so we're just going to in our model
we're just going to use the q
um as an integer we're just gonna add
one and subtract one every time we
write that's good enough to test our
model there's no point making it more
complicated that
so that's the programming language
version now let's look at the tla plus
version
so same kind of thing if you're in the
ready state and
the cue size is less than this and
now this is again it's not it's not um
it's not assignment so all three things
have to match
for this transition to be valid okay so
afterwards the cues
the producer states in right and the
queue size is unchanged now this is one
of the differences between
tla and a programming language is that
every variable has to be accounted for
in a state transition you can't just say
i don't care what happens to the cue
size
you have to specifically say either i am
changing the cue size or i'm not
changing the cue size
you have to specifically say that always
so i have to specifically say the cue
size is not changing
okay so that's the first bit uh now the
second bit
similar kind of thing if i'm in the
right mode and i can transition
to the read mode i'm into the ready
state and i can add one to the queue
and um uh that's the two different
transitions
now overall as a producer um
the two things i can do is i can either
go i can do the first transition
or the second transition i can do the
check part or i can do the right part
so it's this or that it's the upside
down uh triangle
is all so that's everything i can do as
a producer
now let's look at a consumer it's pretty
much the same kind of idea
um we can check whether it's readable
um if the cue size is bigger than zero i
can read
otherwise i can't read um and i
transition to the
read can read state and the queue size
is unchanged
and then on when i actually do a read i
have to be i have to start off in one
state
and then i transition to the other state
and at the same time i
take something off the queue so that's
the check
and the read for the consumer and again
the consumer as a whole
has two parts you can either do the
check or we can do the read
so it's all so we've got the consumer
action and we've got the
producer action so if we combine them
let's just i should show the entire
valid script here we have to also in a
proper tla script
we have to list the variables we're
using and i'm going to assign the
maximum queue size to be two
it's a model it doesn't need to be like
10 000 long
it just needs to be a few long because
that's all we need to check the all
possible states
so the initial state is that both both
things are ready
and the queue size is zero and then um
the producer will type you know this is
the same code i showed you a minute ago
for the producer
and then this is the same code i showed
you a minute ago for
the consumer and then finally
the overall all the possible state
transitions we can do is either we can
do a producer action
or we can do a consumer action so we got
choice between the two
now what's interesting is when we write
this we've actually got a
non-deterministic
system we've got you might think of it
as two different processes or two
different threads
or two different actors they're kind of
running in parallel
um in tla plus this is completely
natural i don't have to like create a
special
thread or process or something we just
say these two things can happen either
these two things happen at any time
and we get uh you know parallel
uh behaviors happening at the same time
it's just kind of cool
so that's one of the things that's
really nice about tla plus it's why it's
so good for concurrency you don't need
to
do anything clever to get kind of
currency happening
um something else i should point out is
that we don't have any stuttering
because this
system these loops will go they'll go
round and round in a loop
so there'll never be a point where
there'll be a deadlock hopefully
should we add stuttering anyway though
should we add the fact that everything
could stay unchanged
and that's a good question and what's
what happens if you think of things
being unchanged you can actually use
this to model
the systems crashing like if the
producer isn't producing anything
um you know how would you detect that
could you handle that
maybe you need to monitor the cue size
and uh you know
if the queue hasn't changed size for a
while that's a flag or something
you can actually model that very nicely
in in tla plus so that's kind of cool
um so what are the properties what are
the properties we want over time
for this uh model well the main one we
wanted was
it was always within bounds the cue size
is always greater than zero and the cue
size is always less than the maximum
so you should be able to read this now
cue size is greater than zero and
q size is is less than the max and that
whole thing is always true for every
possible state
so if we run this there's eight possible
states it can be in
and there are no errors so that's great
so the invariant
of the queue size being out of bounds is
never going to happen
with one producer and one consumer we
have a lot of confidence in this design
but with one producer and one consumer
so we're not guessing
anymore i trust that the model checker
worked and it checked all the states
and everything worked properly so that's
good i have confidence for this one
now let's do the concurrent one and see
what happens there
so this is when we have more than one
producer and more than one consumer
um accessing the same queue and this is
now we need the plus part of tla plus uh
which is the set theory
um so again this is a mathematical thing
uh tla plus uses sets and
you know if we use a program language
and we want to like
filter out a subset of something we
would use a keyword
a method called filter or something um
in tla plus you'd say
all the elements in the set such that
this predicate is true
which is the mathematical way of saying
it uh if we wanted to see
find all the elements in the set where
something was true does there exist an
element which is true
uh you know in a programming language
you probably say you know any
is there anything in the set which is
true but in tla plus we use mathematical
conventions and we say does there exist
an element x in the set
s such that this predicate is true
so when you see all these slash a's and
slash ins
that is set notation in tla plus
so it looks a bit scary but once you get
used to it once you
start recognizing for what it was it's
not as scary as you might think
okay so we're going to need a set of
producers and a
set of consumers and we need to use the
set description part of tla plus so our
code is going to get a little more
ugly unfortunately so here we have two
producers and two consumers that's what
we're going to pass in
so here's the specification for the
multi
producer consumer one um there are
presumably now we're going to have the
producer state and the consumer state
but this time
they're going to be dictionaries they're
going to be maps
uh i'll explain that in a minute that's
the same
initialization is slightly different um
so let me just take you through this
these are now a dictionary or a map
where it's a bunch of key value pairs
and the key is the producer or the
consumer
and the value is the state of that
producer or consumer
so when we do something like this what
we're saying is for every
producer uh assign the the the value for
that to be
ready so if you're used to python or
something it's the same as that little
bit of code underneath
p1 is ready p2 is also ready
now to check whether something is
writable the code looks a little bit
different as well
this is now parameterized for a
particular producer this code is now so
we can pass in a parameter to these
things
and this now says uh the producer state
at that key
is that is that ready for that
particular producer is the state ready
uh the cue size is the same
and now that afterwards the producer
state
is um we can't just update one part we
have to say the entire producer state is
exactly the same except for this one
thing
so the new producer state afterwards is
the same as the original producer state
except that one key value pair has been
changed
and for this particular producer the key
the state has been changed to can write
so that's why it uses the word accept
because it's the original set
except this one thing has changed
similarly on the other side of the right
side similar kind of logic
we update the state except for it's now
ready now the producer action
also looks different because what we now
have here
is we have a lot of producers so what
we're going to do is try and find
any producer that we can do one of these
transitions does there exist
a producer in the set of producers that
we can either
do either the check transition or we can
do the right transition
um so we're just going to try and find
any of the users and it doesn't matter
which one we pick
it's non-deterministic
now on the consumer side it's very very
similar we have privatized version of
the readable
thing again it's now parameterized by
consumer
uh the key value for that you know the
we look up that consumer
as the key and if the value is ready
that's good
and again when we update the state it's
exactly the same as it was before except
that the key value for this one has
changed to can read
so that's what that logic is and again
the read logic is very similar so now
we're just using set notation a lot more
rather than individual
things and again for the consumer side
of things um
we have to say does there exist a
consumer uh that
can go to one of these two states can it
read or kind of uh you know can we do
the check transition can we do the
retransition
is there a consumer that will do that
so we run this script we run the model
checker
um with two producers and two consumers
and the same always with bounds property
there are 38 different estates uh 38
states we can't possibly check
38 distinct states by hand and we get
this error
the invariant is violated so this is not
true we are confident this design does
not work
unlike the before when we were guessing
so no need to guess
we can be confident that we're right or
wrong
so tla plus won't tell you how to fix
the error
um you have to think okay but
when you want to test the fixes you just
update the model with the fix so let's
say i want to make the operations atomic
or i want to add locks or whatever it is
i update the model to do these things
and then i can rerun the model checker
and
whatever the model checker says i now
have a lot more confidence that the fix
does work or the fix doesn't work
but you know my confidence is very high
rather than just guessing
like if i had a lock uh is that going to
work maybe if i have a bit of
wrong logic for locking maybe i might
have white logic locks are
tricky too now this is all in 50 lines
of code
so this is a really nice little script
that we can use
for doing um our check in our models
so okay last bit i'm running out of time
i'm going to go a few minutes over
sorry about that but we're now going to
use tla plus
to do a zero downtime deployment and
this is kind of a real world example
i want to do i want to have a zero
downtime deployment of a bunch of
servers
is my logic correct am i making any
mistakes before i actually do it and
and and have a problem so i'm going to
go fast
don't worry about the details i just
want you to get the overall big picture
of
what you can do so tla plus is a great
tool for improving the design process
because you can do these kind of
sketches
in a few lines of code you can check it
you can fix it
you can check it again and you can
repeat and repeat until
you're happy with the design and it's so
much faster than writing real code codes
you know you can do things in hours or
minutes rather than
month weeks or months so if you think of
it as like
test driven development but from
currency instead of red green refactor
it's red green remodel
you know you get a red your thing
doesn't work you make it work you maybe
you remodel it until everything is green
and then you're happy to go so
what we're going to do what we're going
to model in this situation is a bunch of
servers
each server has to be upgraded from
version one to version two
each server goes offline during the
upgrade and
we want to check that there's always a
server this is online like zero downtime
and all the servers must be upgraded
that's kind of important right if they
all stay at version one there's no
problem
but uh we want to make sure they all go
to version two at some point otherwise
it's not a very good
upgrade and i'm just crediting you know
wayne for the idea for this
uh here's a post on modeling deployments
which i based this example off of so
let's sketch the design
we have a service date in version one we
start the upgrade it goes offline
and when and then we finish the upgrade
and it comes back online again
as version two and then once it's a
version two we're done and we can just
kind of loop around forever in version
two just like we did with the
count to three example so uh
this is the initial states all the
servers are online and in version one
when we start a particular server it
goes if it's in
online and it's in version one it can
all the servers
stays the same except for this
particular one changes to offline
and when we finish it has to be offline
and afterwards
all the servers are the same except this
particular one goes to version two
so that is our model
um now we're going to combine the start
and finish into a single step called
upgrade
and this says try and find a server
where we can do
either the start step or the finished
step so it doesn't access the server
uh that we can do that and then we're
done if all the servers are finished so
if it's true that all the servers
are in online version two we're done and
then we can just say yeah we can just do
our infinite loop at that point which
everything's unchanged after that
so that's the done state and so overall
the entire next
is either do the upgrade step or do the
done step
and that is our entire sketch for the
for the logic for upgrading our service
so like i said i'm whizzing through this
very quickly um
but uh yeah you know you don't have to
understand the example
in the code too much but i just want to
show you this it's not that hard to like
sketch out a design now here's the thing
we want to check and see does this work
right so with one server we have three
states which is probably what we'd
expect
and the number of states goes up
exponentially as you add more servers
and uh it's really hard to eyeball for
errors
so we're going to do the model checker
to make sure we haven't forgotten
anything
so let's add some temporal properties
um we want zero downtime that's a really
important one and that means not all
servers should be offline at once and we
want the upgrade to complete
so that means all the servers should
eventually be version two
so let's write the code for that it's
always true there exists a server that's
not offline
so we say uh it's always true that there
exists a server
that's not offline always there's a
server
where the server state is not offline
and not
uh is slash equals is tla plus for not
equals
like bang equals okay what about the
other one
eventually upgraded that what does that
mean that means eventually
all the servers uh the state for that
server is version two
so that's the set logic and the tempo
logic combined
it's eventually true that for all the
servers service date
is going to be version two that's what
it means to be eventually upgraded
so let's run this script with two
servers
and we get the zero downtime violation
straight away
because there's something wrong with our
model and
the ch the trace tells us exactly what
went wrong server one
uh went offline and then server two went
offline and now they're both offline
and that's bad so that that uh
invariant was violated straight away
well okay
uh i've got an idea we could fix this um
and how can we be sure that our fix will
work well let's check it with the model
checker
so we're going to add a new condition
for the starting and upgrade we're going
to say you can only start an upgrade
if no other servers are offline and that
way only one server can be offline at a
time
so this is this new transition if
there exists another server which the
server is offline
then don't start the upgrade okay
so only one at a time can be offline and
they can't all be offline at the same
time
so other than that it's the same so if
you run this model
uh the zero time now works so it's
always true
that uh you never have any downtime
that's much better confidence
however eventually upgraded fails
okay why does it fail because of
stuttering because
in our code uh the model says it just
stays at version one forever
yeah well that's not very helpful so the
way to fix that is to add a fairness
condition
and we had a fairness condition and now
it works so if we
uh do this we now have complete
confidence in this particular
design this is great now let's add one
more condition
let's say that all the servers have to
be running the same version which is a
decent condition to have they all have
to be running either version one or
version two
so here's all the lists of all the
services the set of servers all the
servers which are not offline
that's the set of online servers and
it's always true
that you take any two servers in the
list of online servers
and they have the same version
now if you run the script with this
property we immediately get an error
again
the same version it's not always true
well why is it not always true
well because server one goes offline and
server one comes back online
upgraded server two is still online and
it's a version 1.
um so that it breaks straight away so
the model checker
found a logic bug straight away with our
design which might not have been obvious
this is the kind of thing it gets more
more subtle we might not have been aware
of that if we hadn't if we hadn't
checked it
now the classic way to fix this is to
add a load balancer
so let's add a load balancer um we're
going to add a load balancer
variable and it's just going to point to
version 1 servers or version 2 service
so the load balancer initially starts to
it starts pointing
uh at version one service so what do you
mean by the online servers well it
depends on the load balancer if the load
balance says version one
it's gonna all the online servers are
version one service
and if the if it's not version one then
all the online servers are version two
service
so that's our very crude model of a load
balancer
that's about as comp you know it's a
very simplistic model but
it's enough to check our logic okay
now when does it switch over to version
two well
when one server manages to switch over
to version two
we can then switch the entire load
balancer over to point to the version
two pool
so the load back as soon as one of them
successfully upgrades we can start
pointing the load balancer that one
and then all the other ones can upgrade
and they're in their own time
so we switch over when one of them has
finished upgrading
so if we run this script with the load
balancer logic
everything still work the previous ones
still work which is important to check
and the same version works
so all our constraints all our
properties are true
for the entire system and i have a lot
of confidence that this is a good design
i can now code this and put it into
production you know
with with high confidence so that's
great so this is the um
i'm just going to go a few minutes over
sorry the sketch is complete
uh you can think of tla plus as agile
modeling like it just took a few minutes
to do that sketch
and it saves you know 10 minutes of
doing a sketch as opposed to a few hours
or a few weeks of programming
definitely a good thing um much much
more confidence
so some common questions before i finish
up um
how do you handle failures well that's
easy you just add failure cases so
if the upgrade failed how would i model
that well i just add a state called
upgrade
failed rather than you know and we have
to handle all those cases too
and a very common question is how does
this convert code
and the answer is it doesn't this is not
a code generator this is a tool for
thinking
just like an architectural model is not
a blueprint uh it's a tool for thinking
about whether you've got the right
thing it's really about having
confidence
so just like an architectural model it's
a way of checking are you doing the
right thing before you spend a lot of
time
doing the implementation so to finish up
tla and one thing is not that scary
it looks a bit scary when you look at
the code but the concepts are actually
pretty straightforward
think of it as agile modeling and you'll
be doing really well
and i think if you're doing any kind of
concert concurrency systems it's kind of
really important
to use it check it out um having a good
toolbox
in your development arsenal is a good
thing to have
um tla plus can do a lot more than i
show today
it can do model checking but it can also
do refinements it can do proofs you can
do
a lot of stuff i just touched the scrape
the surface today
uh for more information there's a very
good page tla plus home page
it's got a video it's got a massive book
a lot of papers
and there's also learn tla.com website
and there's a book
called practical tla by hillel wayne and
he also does trainings
so you want someone to train your team
in cla plus
contact him and i'm sure he would be
happy to do that
so thanks very much i will put the
slides up
on my website f sharp on profit
tla plus and um if you are interested in
other kinds of things i have a book the
main modelling made functional which has
nothing to do with this but i have to
promote it anyway
because i'm an author and that's what
authors do but um
please feel free to contact me on
twitter or contact me on the slack
the ndc slack afterwards i'm happy to
stay around ask questions
and um thank you very much and uh see
you next time